وبين اول ايام العيد وسابع ايام الحرب
ترتسم صوره السودان اليوم وعلى وقع
استمرار الصوره المشوشه في الخرطوم لا شيء
يوحي بان مسارا ما يجنح بالبلاد نحو
التهدئه الجيش السوداني وقوات دعم السريع
كلاهما اعلن السيطره على وسط الخرطوم وعلى
مرافق حيويتها من جانبه اكد البيت الابيض
ان لا قرار حتى اللحظه باجلاء الرعايه
الامريكيين رغم تاكيد مقتل امريكي بسبب
القتال الدائر في السودان
[موسيقى]
من النفخ للعربيه كل جيش بس تنشيط ما يدعم
سريع ما في ملائكه اضمنكم من امام الساحه
الخضراء ما في اي حاجه كله ينتهى والله
مبروك والله
اطمن الناس
اسرع المسلح في السودان يستمر وتستمر
الحرب بالتاكيد تاثير على حياه المدنيين
تقارير صحفيه عديده اشارت الى مشاركه
مدنيين في العمليات هذه مشاهد فيديو
متداوله تظهر مقيله انه مسانده من قبل
مدنيين للجيش السوداني خلال العمليات
العسكريه في البلاد بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وعلى طرف النقيض ايضا هذه الصور لمواطن
سوداني يقوم بالدعاء لافراد من قوات الدعم
السريع
يا رب يا رب يا رب
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
لمتابعه الاوضاع ميدانيه انضموا الينا من
الخرطوم الزميل سالم الهاشمي مراسل
العربيه مرحبا بك مجددا سالم العنوان
الرئيسي ان محيط المعارك يتم في العاصمه
الخرطوم ومحيطها كيف تبدو صور المعارك
الان
نعم هي في الخرطوم فعلا وفي وسط الخرطوم
تحديدا في اتجاه القياده العامه وما حولها
وكذلك تمتد هذه الاشتباكات الى منطقه كذلك
في منطقه المظلات بالقرب بين بحري وام
درمان وكذلك
كافوري كذلك وفي هاتين منطقتين هناك معسكر
ربما هنالك التحركات كذلك من الجيش
السوداني وكذلك من الدعم السريع
السيطره على المناطق التي حوادث بها
يمكن القول بانها الدعم السريع الى
المحافظه التي هو متواجد بها والجيش
السوداني يريد ان
يخرج الدعم السريع من هذه المناطق وبعدها
بالنسبه
اين تكمن مناطق سيطره قوات الدعم السريع
في العاصمه
وكذلك الشعبيه شمال
من الشمال
وهذا الشمال والجنوب اما من الشرق والغرب
من الغرب من جهه جسر الشمات وحتى
حديد
بها قوات
اذا من له السيطره على منطقه وسط الخرطوم
وفقا لمشاهداتك على الارض لان البيانات
العسكريه بين الجانبين متناقضه للغايه
القياده العامه
لكن الجيش
من داخل القياده العامه يقول انه يسيطر
على القياده العامه للداخلها وربما هذا مع
حديث لقيادات الجيش السوداني بانهم
متواجدون في داخل القياده العامه
ولكن
تحاول ان توضح لنا اكثر من يتواجد الان
داخل القياده العامه في الخرطوم
نعم بحسب الحديث الذي ذكره الجيش السوداني
انهم متواجدون في الاخير هذا العام
طيب بدا الحديث منذ اندلاع هذه الازمه عن
مساله اجلاء الرعايه هل من اتصالات تمت
بالفعل مع الاطراف السودانيه لمساله اجلاء
الرعايه خاصه الامريكيين هناك انباء
تتوارث حول هذا الامر
نعم بالنسبه لاجلاء الرعايه ربما يمكن
القول بان هذا الامر يتم
الاتفاق بين الطرفين على هذا الامر لكن في
هذا التوقيت يصعب الحديث عن هذا الاتفاق
خاصه في ظل تصاعد وثيقه هذا اليوم واليوم
الذي قبله وكذلك هناك تصاعد الاشتباكات
لكنها تخبط احيانا وتزيد احيانا لكنها
موجوده على كل حال
الصوت يتقاطع سالم
نعم
تفضل
ذكرت لك بانه
من الصعب الحديث عن هذا الموضوع في هذا
التوقيت مع تجدد الاشتباكات ومع ايضا
التحركات التي يجريها الجيش السوداني في
المناطق التي يشتد فيها الصراع وتتعالى
فيها اصوات السلاح
منك ان ترسم لنا صوره
يتم تقريبها للمشاهد
الشاشه كيف تبدو طبيعه هذه المواجهات هل
نحن نتحدث عن قوات تدخل مع قوات اخرى
باطلاق اسلحه باستخدام اسلحه
متوسطه باستخدام اسلحه ثقيله ما الذي يحدث
لا احد يعرف كيف تتم هذه المواجهات تحديدا
على الارض
نعم هي تختلف من منطقه لاخرى في الخصوم
وهذا الامر يتضح جليا بحسب اصوات الاسلحه
التي تسمع فحينما يكون هناك قصف بالطائرات
فمن المؤكد ان قوات الدعم السريع هنا في
مكان الدفاع الطائرات والجيش السوداني في
مكان الهجوم بهذه الطائرات على المواقع
التي تتمركز فيها
[موسيقى]
مباشره ما بين قوات الجيش قوات الدعم
السريع كالقياده العامه مثلا
سالم الهاشمي مراسل العربيه من الخرطوم
شكرا لك سالم وسنبقى معك في هذه التغطيه
الحيه والمباشره والان نتابع ايضا جنوب
الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد حسن
مرحبا بك مقداد كيف تبدو الصوره في جنوب
العاصمه هناك تباين حول من يسيطر على
الجنوب والوسط من يسيطر على الجنوب وفقا
للمواجهات التي تتم
اهلا رشاد بطبيعه الحال ان هناك ان هذه
المنطقه تتمركز فيها
مدرعات او ما تعرف بمدرعات الشيء الشجره
وهي منطقه تحتدم فيها المعارك منذ الايام
الاولى لبدايه هذا الصراع المسلح بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني هنالك كروه
فر بين هذه القوات
في صبيحه هذا اليوم واول ايام عيد الفطر
كانت هنالك معارك عنيفه جدا واصوات
للمدافع الثقيله والرشاشات وكذلك سمعنا او
راينا تحليق الطائرات في هذه المنطقه تدوب
سماء الخرطوم
بدا هذا اليوم عنيفا كانت هنالك اصوات
الاذان واصوات التكبيرات تكبيرات العيد
تتعالى واصوات الرصاص والمدافع كذلك
تتعالى
فمن يسيطر على من
قوات الدعم السريع تنتشر في جزيره السرعه
وتعيد موضوعها في مناطق مختلفه لا لا نقدر
لا نستطيع ان نجزم بان هذه المنطقه
بالسيطره عليها من الدعم السريع او الجيش
السوداني لان
المعارك تحت تدور
بكثافه في هذه
المنطقه لكن بحسب ما رشح اليه الينا ان
القوات الدعم السريع الان
خرجت الى شارع مدني او المنطقه الجنوبيه
للخرطوم كانت هنالك معارك محتدمه في منطقه
الصح افه قبل قليل واثناء في هذه المنطقه
هنالك اعمده دخان تتصاعد من اسقف او تقاطع
ابو حمامه وهي منطقه تبعد مني الان حوالي
كيلومترين
الذين يتواجدون في هذه المناطق الحصيله
بين الساعه والاخرى للاسف ترتفع
للاسف المواطنون يعيشون اوضاعا انسانيه
وماساويه صعبه العيد كان كان حزينا يعني
لا تجد ان هنالك عيدان غالب الاحاديث
فهل تجدد القصف مجددا
نعم هذا القصف ياتي من مناطق بعيده ربما
لاننا قريبين من من وعلى بعد كيلومترات
عده من منطقه وسط الخرطوم التي تحتدم فيها
المعارك هذه الاصوات تاتي من هذه المنطقه
على على على الاغلب وكذلك
الجهه الجنوبيه من هذه المنطقه التي انا
فيها الان منطقه شارع الغابه هنالك قوات
الجيش السوداني
تمركز بالمدرعات
القذائف تاتي بصوره كثيفه في في اوقات
مختلفه من اليوم هنالك هدوء نسبي في بعض
التابعه
نعم هذه المدرعات مدرعات تتبع لقوات الجيش
السوداني في في المنطقه الشماليه وكذلك
هنالك المصنع الذخيره في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم هذه المنطقه
لا تستطيع ان
تنام بصوره هادئه في في طيله ايام السابقه
هل المنطقه هنا تعودوا على هذه الاصوات
واصبح جزء طبيعي من حياتهم الكل يحس
ويعاني ويتوقع باي لحظه ان يفقد حياته او
ان يفقد جزءا من ممتلكاته الماليه او
الماديه او الشخصيه هنالك صعوبه بالغه في
ايصال المتعثرين والمتضررين والاحوال
الانسانيه صعبه خصوصا ان هذه المنطقه
بالقرب منها
مستوصف او او مستشفى وهو مستشفى معروف في
هذه المنطقه هذا المركز
ايضا تتوارث حول هذا الامر
نعم هنالك اسر كثيره تضررت نحن راينا بهم
اعيننا وصورنا كذلك احداث ماساويه في مجمع
الرواد السكني الذي
وقعت قذيفه في هذه الافراد السكنيه وهي
منطقه معروفه في جنوب الخرطوم وقعت قذيفه
الضحيتها والده
زوجه او او زوجه لهذه الاسره والد الزوجه
عبد الله الذي اجرينا معه مقابله بالامس
هذا احد الضحايا وكذلك رشحت الينا اخبار
في منطقه منطقه الغوز او الرميله وهي كذلك
هي الاخرى تضررت من هذه المدافع والقذائف
التي تسقط احيانا بصوره عشوائيه
هذه الاشتباكات وهذه
الصراع الصراع بين الجيش السوداني يحاولون
النجاه بانفسهم ويحاولون ان يؤمنوا
لانفسهم مسكنا امنا ويحاول ان يقدموا ما
يستطيعون كيتكاتفوا في المواجهات المسلحه
مستمره حتى الان في جنوب الخرطوم بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وحتى
اللحظه املاء محدده حول كيفيه الوصول الى
وقف لهذه المواجهات الصحفيين مقداد حسن من
جنوب الخرطوم شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات
سنتابع مع حضراتكم هذا القصف هذه صور
للعاصمه الخرطوم وهذا هو صوت حيه للقصف
المتبادل بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني الان
واعتزلنا العاصمه هي محور هذه المواجهات
حتى اللحظه حلول عيد الفطر لم يمنع هذه
المعارك من الاستمرار لاسيما في العاصمه
الخرطوم ونواحيها والتي يشد فيها القتال
في العديد من النقاط الساخنه نتعرف على
ابرد هذه النقاط
في العيد في السودان فدوى المدافع لا يزال
يصدح في مختلف ارجاء الخرطوم ونواحيها
خارطه المعارك تتغير بشكل مستمر في ظل
تغير المعطيات على ارض الميدان وبشكل عام
فان الاقتتال لا يزال متمركزا فيما يسمى
بالعاصمه المثلثه والمقصود بها الخرطوم
المدينه والخرطوم بحري او الخرطوم شمال
الى جانب ام درمان في الخرطوم المدينه فان
المعارك الدائره في النقاط الساخنه انتقلت
الى محيطها والحديث هنا عن مطار الخرطوم
ومقر القياده العامه فضلا عن القصر
الجمهوري فاذا كانت قوه الجيش قد نجحت في
وقت سابق في السيطره على المطار نفسه فان
الاقتتال انتشر في محيطه الشيء ذاته في
مقر القياده العامه الذي يشهد محيطه معارك
داريه اما في القصر الجمهوري فان
الاشتباكات مستمره بين الطرفين من اجل
السيطره على المبنى عمليه الكر والفر بين
الجانبين ادت الانتقال الاقتتال الى مناطق
واحياء ايضا ابرزها تلك الدائره على
امتداد شارع الستين في الجزء الشمالي
الشرقي للعاصمه وفي ام درمان وبينما توقف
الاغتال حول محيط مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون
شهد شمال المدينه اقتتالا عنيفا بين
الجانبين وتحديدا في جبل استركاب معركه
انتهت بسيطره قوه الجيش على قاعده عسكريه
كانت تابعه لقوات الدعم وفي الخرطوم بحري
فان ابرز الاشتباكات تدور حول معسكر
المظلات الذي تسيطر عليه قوات الدعم
السريعه وفضلا عن النقاط الساخنه للاقتتال
فان الجيش دشن عمليات تمشيط واسعه حيث
جابت دوريات مشاه عده احياء في العاصمه
ونواحيها وسام الذهبي العربيه
والحيويه على مستوى الدوله السودانيه
نحن كقوات الدعم السريع معروفين بالقتال
والشراسه والبساله
عن حقنا وندافع عن الشعب السوداني ونحن
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو الوضع فيما يتعلق بالمواجهات الوضع
الانسانيه اصعب بكثير حيث قالت منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود الدوليه ان فريقها الطبي
لا يمكنه ادخاله اي امدادات طبيه اضافيه
الى السودان في ظل الشبكات الحاليه محضره
بانه ان لم يتغير الوضع في المنطقه سيكون
هناك المزيد من الخسائر في الارواح اشارت
المنظمه ايضا في بيان الى ان الامدادات
التي تقدمها في مستشفى الفشر ستكفي فقط
لثلاثه اسابيع اضافيه في حال عدم ادخال اي
امدادات جديده الى المستشفى
هذا واعرب مدير الوكاله الدوليه للتنميه
والعون الانسانيه الصادق محمد احمد
للعربيه عن خشيته من تفشي الامراض
بالسودان جراء وجود الجثث في الشوارع طبعا
حرج جدا فيما يتعلق بامدادات الغذاء وايضا
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني في المستشفيات
خصوصا لان الان اصبح هناك ازمه انسانيه
كبيره اضيفت الى نقص الغذاء ونقص المواد
التموينيه وظيفه اليها اخلاء الجرحى من
الشوارع هناك كارثه انسانيه يعني
تحيط يعني بالوضع بصوره عامه والنقشه ان
يتم ايضا انتشار الامراض من جراء وجود بعض
الجثث الكثير من الجثث الان في الشوارع
ولم يتم باخلاقها وستتحلل بمرور الايام
هذا وقال عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
الاطباء في السودان العربيه ان 11 طبيبا
قتلوا خلال المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع بالاضافه الى تعرض عدد من
المستشفيات الى القصف ما تسبب بتوقف عمل
بعض المستشفيات
احد عشر من الكوادر الطبيه
هم ثمانيه من القواعد الطبيه وثلاثه من
طلاب كليات الطيب
تعدت اسباب قتلهم اما بالرصاص المباشر او
سقوط دهانات داخل منازلهم نعم احد عشر في
مجموعهم 14 مستشفى تعرضت للقصف المباشر او
الغير مباشر في النهايه هي تعرضت لدمار
جزء او دمار كامل ايضا هنالك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعرضت للعنف وبعض منهم
مصاب
للعنف الذي واجهوه في الشوارع اثناء
قيامهم باداء واجبهم تجاه
المستشفيات القادمه والمرضاهم
مع حضراتكم هذا القصف المتجدد بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تستمعون الى هذا القصف عبر الهواء مباشره
هذا القصف مستمر لليوم السابع على التوالي
ولا بوادر حتى اللحظه على تشكل اراده
حقيقيه لوقف طويل المدى لاطلاق النار لم
تتشكل هذه الاراده بعد والقصف مستمر محيط
هذا القصف يتركز بشكل واضح في العاصمه
الخرطوم شمالا ووسطا وجنوبا وسط تبادل
للبيانات العسكريه ما بين الجانبين كل طرف
يدعي انه يسيطر على مناطق اكبر في العاصمه
الخرطوم وحتى اللحظه الغموض هو ما يسيطر
على هذا المشهد دون وضوح اي طرفين متقدم
حتى اللحظه
نحن سنستمر في متابعه هذه الصور الحيه
وهذا القصف المستمر ولكن سنذهب ايضا
لتحليل هذا المشهد مع دكتوره اماني الطويل
مديره البرنامج الافريقي بمركز الاهرام
للدراسات مرحبا بك دكتور اماني دكتور
اماني هناك من يرى ان وقف اطلاق النار لن
يتم الا اذا تم او تمت الخطوه التاليه وهي
ترتيب الاوضاع بعد هذا الوقف لاطلاق النار
على ماذا سيحصل حميدتي وعلى ماذا سيحصل
البرهان
اهلا بك رشا واهلا بالمشاهدين يعني دعيني
اقول ان وقف اطلاق النار يجب ان يكون
عمليه شامله بمعنى انه صحيح ان الظرف
الانساني مرعب وان المدنيين يعانون معاناه
هائله وان الوضع الصحي في الخرطوم مقلق
ويسبب مشاكل انسانيه كبيره ولكن كل هذه
المعطيات لن تؤثر في طرفي الصراع العسكري
في المشهد اللي احنا شايفينه دلوقتي فمن
يطالب اطلاق النار الحقيقه او من يطالب
بالتهدئه
باتصور انه يجب ان يكون هناك
اليات لي ان تكون هذه التهدئه قابله
او الهدنه قابله للتنفيذ وايضا وقف اطلاق
النار قابل للتنفيذ
اسالها وعندي يجب ان يكون نعم سنعود لهذا
الامر ولكن هناك نقطه يفكر فيها الجميع
الان كل طرف يحاول بس سيطرته على الارض
الكل يفكر انه اذا كان هناك اقناع للطرفين
بوقف اطلاق النار لابد ان تسبقه تفاهمات
ما ما الذي سيحدث ما بين الرجلين حميدتي
والبرهان
يعني ليس بالضروره ان يكون هناك تفاهمات
بين الرجلين ولكن انا اتصور انه من الممكن
تقديم مشروع من جهه
وسيطه بنقاط محدده يوافق عليها الطرفين
وتكون هذه الجهه ضامنه لهذه المساله
التفاهم بين الطرفين في هذه اللحظه لا
يملك الحقيقه اليات ولا اعتقد انهم قادرين
على مستوى شخصي لا في يعني التباحث حول
تفاهمات ولا في احراز نتائج لهذه
التساهمات الرجلين قد قال في بعضهم البعض
ما لا لا يعني ما لا يمكن ان يقال او يسمح
به وبالتالي انا اتصور ان وقفا لاطلاق
النار يجب ان
يتطلب او يتضمن نقاط تنفيذيه نقاط يقبلها
الطرفان كلنا يدفع الطرفين اطلاق النار
نعم ما الذي سيدفع الطرفين على الارض حتى
هذه اللحظه رشا على الارض حتى هذه اللحظه
ليس هناك دافع لاي طرف حتى يقدم مثل هذا
التنازل عندما اسلفتي ان المشهد الميداني
المشهد الميداني بيقول انه لا احد متقدم
صحيح ان مشهد القياده العامه اليوم مختلف
عن الامس صحيح ان الادخنه المنطلقه من
مبلغ من مبنى القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه مختلف عن الامس الجيش
يقول انه سيطر بالكامل ربما تكون هناك بعض
المناوشات ربما هذا يحسب للجيش يعني يحسب
نقاط تقدم للجيش لكن اذا كانت المعارك قد
خفت عند القياده العامه وهي تحمل قيمه
رمزيه ومعنويه كبيره
لكن نلاحظ ان المعارك قد اشتدت في احياء
جنوب الخرطوم بما يعني ان قوات الدعم
السريع قد انسحبت الى هذه
الاحياء وانها مازالت تستخدم تكتيك
الاحتماء بالمدنيين وانها تقاوم الخروج من
الخرطوم لانها سوف تكون في هذه الحاله
صيدا سهلا لسلاح الطيران السوداني طيب
دكتور نحن نتابع وحضرتك معنا على الهواء
هذا القصف المستمر للعاصمه الخرطوم ما بين
الجانبين تبادل للقصف بينهما دكتور من هو
الطرف الذي يمكن ان يقوم بالوساطه في هذا
التوقيت خاصه ان مواقف الاطراف الاقليميه
تبدو هي الاخرى منقسمه على ما يبدو
صحيح المواقف الاقليميه منقسمه والمصالح
متناقضه وانا اتصور انه ربما الامين العام
للامم المتحده وحده وليس الايجاد وليس
البعثه الاماميه في الخرطوم الامين العام
للامم المتحده نفسه
وعبره يقدم مشروع لوقف اطلاق النار يجب
تنحيد فولكر من هذا المشهد يجب تنحيه
الايجاد من هذا المشهد يجب ان تنحيه دول
الاقليم من هذا المشهد طيب بما يستفيد
الامين العام
تفضلي طيب دكتور نحاول ان نفكر معا بصوت
عالي حمدتي المساله بالنسبه له بالطبع
الان هي مساله حياه او موت ربما ايضا
بالنسبه للبرهان هي المساله اكون او لا
اكون في الحقيقه انا لا ضمانات حقيقيه
للرجلين معا ماذا لو تم وقف اطلاق النار
والوصول الى تسويه ما البعض يعتقد انه حتى
في حال اقرار حكومه مدنيه في هذا التوقيت
ليست هناك ضمانات من عدم ملاحقه الرجلين
قضائيا
لا هو في ضمانات يعني كان من المفترض طبقا
للاتفاق الايطالي وقبل الاتفاق الايطالي
وكان في المجال العام السوداني قد طرحت
افكار فيما يتعلق بالعداله الانتقاليه
العداله الانتقاليه مساله لها اليات وصدقه
يعني تم تطبيقها في دول كثيره
وهي كفيله بانه لا يعني لا نواجه مثل هذا
المشهد انه
رجلين يخرجان من او اي يعني طرف سياسي او
عسكري يخرج من المشهد
ولا تتم ملاحقته هناك اليات محدده وهناك
تجارب دول وهناك اطر قانونيه تضمن هذه
المساله التي تسمى بالخروج الامن
وظن في ورشه من ورشه ما قبل الاتفاق
النهائي اللي هي الورشه المترتبه على
الاتفاق الاطاري كانت تسمى العداله
الانتقاليه لكن نتيجه التجاذب السياسي لم
تصل الى نتائج المرحله الحاليه بعد ان وقع
هذا الصراع المسلح المرحله الحاليه
المرحله الحاليه يمكن التوافق على ما يسمى
بالخروج الامن حتى نستطيع ان يعني نمضي
قدما في المشهد السياسي وحتى نستطيع ان
نمضي قدما فيما يسمى بالعمليه السياسيه
طيب هناك بعض الاسئله الاخرى دكتور اماني
بوزن ودور القوات المسلحه في المشهد
المستقبلي نعم نحن لدينا اسئله اخرى ولكن
هذه صور ايضا للعاصمه الخرطوم وكنا نستمع
وحضرتك تتحدثي الان على الهواء الى قصف ما
زال مستمر ما بين الجانبين دكتور اماني
هناك تساؤلات حول طبيعه الصفقه السياسيه
التي يمكن ان تتم ولكن هناك تساؤل ايضا
على ماذا يراهن كلا الطرفين يعني على ماذا
يراهن حماتي وعلى ماذا يراهن البرهان
يعني انا في تقديري ان البرهان لديه مشروع
متكامل وهذا المشروع افصح عن ملامحه بشكل
او باخر خلال الايام الماضيه وهو انه ليس
لي دوله السودان الا جيشا واحدا وان مساله
الدمج او الاعتراف بقوات الدم دعم السريع
هي من التاريخ
هذا هو مشروع البرهان اما مشروع حماتي فهو
ينطلق من فكره ان يكون بديلا للقوات
المسلحه ان تكون قوات الدعم السريحيه بديل
للقوات المسلحه
وان تكون حاضنه السياسيه هو تحالف الحريه
والتغيير المركزي ما يمكن من جذبه من
اطراف اخرى وان يتعهد بالتحول الديمقراطي
وان يتعهد ايضا
بعدم تسليم او يعني اتاحه فرص في المعادله
المستقبليه
لاطراف النظام القديم وخصوصا رموز الجبهه
القوميه الاسلاميه
المشكله الرئيسي في مشروع حماتي انه لا
يملك مصداقيه وان الجميع يعرف انه مجرد
مشروع قائم على يعني ظروف متحركه
وان قابليته او يعني شرعيته في الشارع
العام السوداني
يقول انه يوافق على هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
اعتبارا من اليوم هذا هو اخر التطورات
الجيش السوداني يقول انه يوافق على هدنه
لمده ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من اليوم دكتور
اماني طويله ارجو ان تبقي معنا في هذه
التغطيه ستكون لدينا اسئله اخرى تتعلق
بهذا المشهد التحليليا ولكن هناك ايضا
متابعه حيه للوضع الميداني الذي يشير الى
استمرار للمواجهات والقصد وان كان الجيش
السوداني قد اعلن منذ لحظات قليله انه
يوافق لمده ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من اليوم
كان او كانت قوات الدعم السريع قالت انها
عرضت في وقت سابق مساله الهدنه واكلا
الطرفين اتهم الاخر بمحاوله تعطيل هذه
الهدنه طبعا اليوم كانت هناك اختلاط كبير
كان هناك تكبيرات لعيد الفطر تاتي وسط
الصوت العالي للقصف المتبادل في هذا
الصراع المسلح التي لم تتشكل
خطه ما حتى اللحظه لوقفه الدول ايضا او
المجتمع الدولي يبدو مرتبكا ايضا لا توجد
اي تحركات فاعله لمحاوله اقناع الطرفين
بوقف هذا العنف لحتى لخروج الرعايه
والاجانب من البلاد الجيش السوداني يقول
انه
سيامل ان يلتزم المتمردين بكل متطلبات هذه
الهدنه و وقفي اي تحركات عسكريه الجيش
السوداني يقول انه على استعداد لبدء هدنه
لمده ثلاثه ايام من الان من اليوم على ان
يلتزم
المتمردين على حد وصفي وهو متعلق بقوات
الدعم السريع
بشروط هذه الهدنه
هذه صور حيه ومباشره لنا للعربيه من قلب
العاصمه الخرطوم
نشعر ان طبعا الليل دخل كانت هناك يعني
اصوات للقصر المتبادل منذ قليل ولكن يبدو
الان ان هناك هدوء لا نعرف اذا كان هذا هو
الهدوء الناتج عن
تفاهمات ما لبدء هذه الهدنه بالفعل ام لا
خاصه ان الجيش السوداني قال انه موافق
بالفعل على هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا
من اليوم
والرد سيكون ايضا من قوات الدعم السريع
وهذا ما يترقبه الجميع الان بالطبع
القصف مستمر حتى اللحظه
نشاهد مع حضراتكم هذه الاصوات التي تتعالى
لتبادل اطلاق النار ما بين الجانبين الجيش
السوداني اعرب منذ قليل عن موافقته على
عقد هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من
اليوم على ان تلتزم قوات الدعم السريع
بشروط هذه الهدنه لا توجد استجابه او رد
فعل من قوات الدعم السريعه حتى اللحظه
ولكن بالطبع فمتابع معنى من جنوب الخرطوم
الصحفي مدثر محمد احمد مرحبا بك مدسر كيف
تبدو طبيعه المواجهات والانباء المتعلقه
بعرض الجيش السوداني لقبول فكره وهدنه
لمده ثلاثه ايام هل ترجمت هذه الاخبار على
الارض باي شكل
حتى الان لا يستطيع احد ان هذه الافكار
تعتمد على الارض ام لا لانه يعني كانت
هناك اشتباكات قبل قليل الان لا نسمع اي
اشتباكات في منطقه على اقل هنا في منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم لم لا توجد اشتباكات كانت
هناك قبل ساعه من الان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم على منطقه منطقه السلمه على ما
يبدو او منطقه
ومنطقه ارض المعسكرات بسوبه هذه شهدت كانت
هناك اصوات تاتي لتلك الاتجاهات ولكن في
محيط القياده لا زالت هناك الاشتباكات
متواصله وانت الان تسمعينها يعني على
الهواء هذه الاشتباكات المحيطه القياده لا
زالت متواصله منذ صبيحه اليوم تخف احيانا
وتشتد احيانا ولكن هي متواصله بكل تاكيد
طيب نحاول ان ندقق في الخبر الجيش
السوداني يقول انه وافق على هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من اليوم تعبير وافق
على الهدنه هل يعني ذلك ان قوات الدعم
السريع عرضت هذه الهدنه على الجيش وهو
الان موافق عليها ويمكن ان نلاحظ خلال
الساعات القليله القادمه توقف لاطلاق
النار
هذه الهدنه كانت التي يعني اعلنها الدعم
القوات الدعم السريع موافقتها عليها لمده
ثلاثه ايام بطلب من بحسب ما اعلنت الدعم
السريع باتصالات اقليميه ودوليه واطراف
خارجيه طلبت هذه الهدنه ووافق عليها الدعم
السريع كانت جيش يرفض هذه الهدنه ايضا
كانت هناك مبادره من بعض من قوى المدنيه
التي وقعت على الاتفاق الايطالي
حصلت على تعهدات من الطرفين بالموافقه على
على هدى لمده ثلاثه ايام خلال عطله العيد
لا نعلم حتى الان هل التي قبل بها الجيش
هي الهدنه هي الهدنه التي طرحتها طرف
خارجيه ام هذه الهدنه التي طرحتها قوه
القوى المدنيه التي وقعت على الاتفاق
الايطالي بكل
تاكيد لما الاتفاق على هذه الهدنه ربما
تشهد الخرطوم خلال الثلاث ايام القادمه
هدوءا في هذه الاشتباكات وهدوءا في
الاوضاع على مستوى الارض طب ماذا تلاحظ
انت الان في محيط جنوب الخرطوم
في جنو الخرطوم اليوم يعني لم تشهد
اشتباكات بالمعنى الذي كانت عليه في
الايام الماضيه كان هناك هدوء نسبي الا من
بعض الاصوات المتقطعه هنا وهناك ولكن لا
ترقى الى مستوى ان يكون هناك اشتباكات
شديده كانت هناك اصوات متقطعه بحسب
الانباء التي راجت في ظهيره اليوم ان قوات
الدعم السريع تحرك على امتداد طريق الطريق
السفري بالخرطوم الذي يطلق عليه اصلاح
الخرطوم مدني وهو الطريقه الرابط بين
ولايه الخرطوم ولايه الجزيره كانت هناك
اشتباكات في هذه في هذا الطريق ما بين
القوات الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش
هذه الابتلاءات لم تشهد منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم يعني
قبل نصف ساعه من الان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم ولكن كانت محدوده ولفتره قصيره
طيب لنعيد لنذكر بهذا النبا الهام والعاجل
القوات المسلحه السودانيه تقول انها وافقت
على
هدنه لثلاثه ايام ابتداء من اليوم وتقول
انها تامل ان يلتزم المتمردون بكل متطلبات
الهدنه خلال عيد الفطر ووقف اي تحركات
عسكريه المشهد في السودان
هذا الوقف لاطلاق النار الذي اعلن الجيش
السوداني انه وافق على هدنه من ثلاثه ايام
من جنوب الخرطومه صحفي مدثر محمد احمد
شكرا لك مدثر على هذه المعلومات دخل الليل
وكان هناك استمرار
للقصف في محيط العاصمه الخرطوم الخرطوم هي
محور رئيسي لهذه المواجهات ما بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني كانت هناك
الع من المناطق الملتهبه والساخنه في شمال
ووسط وجنوب الخرطوم وهناك بيانات كالعاده
متناقضه ما بين الجانبين الكل يتحدث عن
انتصاراته العسكريه وتقدمه ولا معلومات
محدده حتى اللقطه حول من يسيطر على الارض
ها هو القصف والمواجهات تتجدد الجميع
يترقب هذا العاجل الذي نتابعه مع حضراتكم
على الشاشه وهو موافقه الجيش السوداني على
هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من اليوم
ولكن حتى اللحظه هذه الهدنه لم تدخل الى
حيز التنفيذ ونحن نتابع مع حضراتكم هذه
المواجهات المستمره بالصوت والصوره من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وينضم الينا
المحل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين مرحبا بك سياده الفريق هل من امل
حقيقي في ان يتم انجاح هذه الهدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام بالفعل
يعني نحن نعمل ان تنجح هذه الهدنه خاصه ان
يعني اصلا السبب الاساسي كان لا يمكن ان
نكون في هدنه اليوم ومعظم الطرق الداخليه
والقوميه مغلقه بعناصر الدعم السريع وهي
تنهب ممتلكات المواطنين العابرين فكان
لابد من نظافه هذه الطرق وجعلها استانكا
للحركه للمواطنين حتى يتمكنوا من يتنقلوا
دون عوائق ودون من نهني يستوقفهم واحد
الان اصبح يمكن ان
ندخل في هدنه يعني القوات المسلحه فقط
لاغراض انسانيه وليس اي غرض اخر
على هذه الهدنه ونامل يعني تمكن الدعم
السريع من تبليغ هذه المعلومه لعناصره لكن
للاسف انا لا غير متفائل حقيقه لانه يعني
واضح جدا انه عن ناصر الدعم الشريحه هذه
اصبحت قوات متفلته وخاليه عن السيطره
ولا اظنها ستنصاع الى اي توجيهات لانه
يعني لها بالعمل العسكري المنظم يعني
حضرتك تقصد ان العناصر التابعه للدعم
السريع على الارض لن تستجيب لدعوات
القياده الخاصه بها لوقف اطلاق النار
المجموعه الغريبه من من قياده
الدعم السريع هي هي التي تحت السيطره وهي
التي يمكن ان تستجيب انها ستستجيب لانه
ذلك وهي استهلكت تمام
ا تماما
الجيش السوداني في بيانه يقول انه وافق
على هدنه وافق من الذي عرض العرض على
الجيش السوداني
لوقف هذا
القتال الان ثلاثه ايام هل من طرف معين
وافق عليهن ولكن القوات المسلحه لم ترد
عليه
يعني قوات الدعم السريع تقول اننا عرضنا
على الجيش السوداني هدنه ولكنه يرفض ذلك
هذا ما كان يقوله الدعم السريع
يعني ان تعمل سريع عرض المسلحه
لم ترد عليه لان الطرق كانت مغلقه فلابد
ان تفتح الطرق اولا ثم ترد عليه الان هي
فتحت الطرق وردت علي موافقين على ثلاثه
ايام هدنه هذا بالضبط ما نقصده
ولكن لماذا تبدو حضرتك غير متفائل بان هذه
الهدنه يمكن ان تتم
لانه ذكرت لك هنالك عدد كبير من عناصر
الدعم السريعه الان اصبحت خارج السيطره
اصبحت اصابات نهت اصابات متفلته وهؤلاء لا
يمكن ان يستجيبوا الى مثل هذا النداء هم
يرغبوا المواطنين يرغبوا اموال الناس
الخاصه وهكذا يعني
طيب هناك معاناه تواجهها الجهات الانسانيه
بشكل كبير انها لا تنجح حتى المنظمات تقول
انها تحاول الاتصال بطرفين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع
لتسهيل وصول الامدادات الى المدنيين الذين
يصابون في هذه الحرب هل من فتح ممرات
انسانيه هل من تقديم مساعده لهذه المنظمات
من قبل الجيش السوداني في هذا التوقيت او
في هذه الايام المقبله
فتح ممرات ثانيه لا
يتوافق الان لان نتحدث عن وقفه فتح
الممرات ثانيه يعني ذلك ان هنالك قوه على
القوتين على الارض كله هو لديها ارض تسيطر
عليها
ويتطلب الامر لكي تمر هذه
المساعدات الانسانيه ان يتوافق
الطرفين لكن الان تعمل سريع ليس لديه ارض
يتفتح عليها حتى نقول نحتاج الى كل دور
بيننا وبينهم يعني لا تعبير لا
بهذه النقطه لانها مهمه ولكن اسمح لنا
سياده الفريق ان نستمع الى بالصوت والصوره
لتجدد القتال والاشتباك بين قوات الدعم
السريع وقوات الجيش السوداني في الخرطوم
نعم رغم اعلان الجيش السوداني عن قبوله
بهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام تم عرضها وفقا
لمصادر عسكريه من الدعم السريع هو من عرض
هذا الاقتراح هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام ولكن
حتى اللحظه هذا للشباك وهذا الاقتتال
الداخلي والصراع المسلح مستمر سياده
الفريق كنت تقول ان الحديث عن مساله ممرات
انسانيه وخروج للاجئين يعني او للنازحين
من هذه المناطق وخاصه الاجانب يعني ان
هناك طرفين على الارض في الحين انك ترى ان
هناك طرف واحد يسيطر وهو الجيش السوداني
اذا لماذا تبدو عمليه تقديم المساعدات
الانسانيه الى المدنيين واجلاء الرعايه
مساله صعبه الان
انا اعتقد ليس ليس صعبه خاصه
ايصال المواد المستهلكات الطبيه
للمستشفيات اذا وجدت اي مستهلكات طبيه في
المستشفيات في اي مكان يريدون ايصالة
للمستشفيات انا اعتقد لو اتصلوا بالناطق
الرسمي لوزاره الصحه ولايه الخرطوم دكتور
محمد ابراهيم سيوفر لهم
الوسيله التي يمكن ان اتصل بها هذه
المعينات هذه ليست معضله ابدا الامر تابعت
بيانات هذه المؤسسات العسكريه وتبعت ايضا
البيانات الامريكيه التي والاوروبيه التي
تتحدث عن صعوبه اجلاء الرعايه نتيجه
استمرار هذا الاقتتال ومنظمات الانسانيه
قالت انه لا تعاون حتى اللحظه من الجانبين
فيما يتعلق بدخول المساعدات
نعم يا فندم بالنسبه لاجراء الرعايه يحتاج
الى وجود مطار محمد
الان المثال الخرطوم غير امن لانه منطقه
حي المطار مسيطر عليها بواسطه العمل
السريع اذا اذا التزمت دعم السريع بوقف
اطلاق النار سيكون مطار الخرطوم امنا
وبالتالي يمكن اجلال كل الرعايه عبر
الخرطوم وهذه عمليه سهله لكن
الدعم السريع شريك فيما يحدث على الارض
الان وبالتالي لن تتمكن منظمات الاغاثه
الانسانيه من تقديم هذا الدعم الا اذا
تعاون الجانبين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع
منذ اليوم الاول وكانت هذه قوات الدعم
السريع المسؤوله عن تامين هذا الحي منذ
اليوم الاول اخذت كل المواطنين في هذا
الحي درع بشري والظل تحتمي به حتى الان
المكان تماما
وبالتالي يصبح المطار مناطفه او مشاركه
بين الجيش السوداني وبين هذه القوات التي
تتمركز في حي المطار وتتخذ من المواطنين
درعا وبالتالي لا يمكن الجيش ان يوافق على
نزول طائره دون موافقه الدعم السريع في
هذا الخرطوم تحديدا لانه
بذلك يكون هنالك خطوره كبيره على الطائرات
لكن اذا التزمت التزمت الدعم السريع في
هذه الهدنه سيكون الخرطوم
لكن النقطه سياده الفريق الجيش السوداني
قال انه وافق على هدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
على ان تبدا من اليوم في اي ساعه ستبدا
القسم ما زال مستمر حتى اللحظه هل نترقب
ان يتوقف هذا القسم المتبادل ما بين
الجانبين وتبدا الهدنه بالفعل بعد ساعه
بعد ساعتين في بدايه الليل ما الذي نتوقعه
بخبرتك العسكريه
احنا اتوقع منذ الساعه السابعه تبدا
الهدنه يعني بعد عشر دقائق تبدا الهدنه
بعد عشر دقائق كما تتوقع
ان الكره في ملعبهم متى ما يوافقون على
موافقون على هنا ولكن حضرتك قلت لي ان
الجيش وافق على هدنه تقدم بها الدعم
السريع يا سياده الفريق نريد ان نفهم بعض
المعلومات لان المشهد يعني غامض بما يكفي
حضرتك قلت لي منذ قليل ان الجيش السوداني
وافق على هدنه تقدمت بها قوات الدعم
السريع اليس كذلك
طيب اذا كيف لا تنفذ الدعم السريع الهدنه
وهي مقدمتها
اخترعت ان تكون الهن اعتبارا من السادسه
صباح اليوم
صباح اليوم يعني قبل اكثر من 12 ساعه
ما كان يمكن ان ترد وتوافق على الهدنه وكل
الطرق على المواطنين مغلقه والمواطن مهدد
في امنه مهدد تنزع منه ممتلكاته وكان لابد
اللغات المسلحه ان تؤمن المواطن ان تفتح
الطرقات ثم بعد ذلك تواجد عن الهدنه الان
الطرقات فتحت ازالت كل
السيطرات التي كان يقيمها الدعم التاريخ
في الشارع الان هي موافقه على يحددهما
الزمن يقولون السابعه من العاشره من غدا
يكون مريحا بالنسبه لهم
من
ناحيهم العسكري لا حاجه لا في هدنه لانها
فارده سيطر على المسرح تستطيع ان
تاتي هاتف
كل القوه تعمل بجزء والجزء يكون مستريح
فاذا لا يعني ليست في حوجه الى هنا
المحتاج الهدنه حنينه والدعم السريع لانه
الان
في هذا التوقيت هم المدنيون في السودان
يعني هؤلاء في امس الحاجه الى هدنه الجرحى
المصابين وبالتالي يجلب الاحتكام الى
الاعتبارات الانسانيه في هذا الامر
انا بقول لك
لكن كل طالب من الاطراف المتنازعه
الاستثمار هذه الهدنه لتحقيق مكسب تعبوي
عندي مشكله في خطوط الامداد اذا كان عندي
مشكله في سياق من الهدنه
هو الذي يحتاج لذلك سياده الفريق اذا كنت
تجلس مثلنا تتابع هذه الاحداث وكل طرف
يقول لك بيان عسكري مختلف عن الاخر الدعم
السريع يقول انه يسيطر من ناحيه وقوات
الجيش السوداني تقول انها تسيطر من ناحيه
هذه صوره ضبابيه لدرجه انه لم يعد احد
يصدق ايا من الجانبين
اقول لك عندما عندما تم غزو
من قبل الامريكيه كنا نستمع الى بيانات
الصحافه وهو يتحدث حتى قبل استلام
لاننا سنلقن ه
ؤلاء هذا هو نفس المشهد
هذا هو نفس المشهد
وانت طبعا تقصد ان ان القوات الدعم السريع
هي من تقدم هذا المثال
ستتضح الصوره
على كل شيء هذا بالضبط موقف عندما تم
الغزوه الامريكي لبغداد هذا هو نفس الموقف
تحدثوا باننا نحن نعمل ونحن نسيطر
ولكن الجميع يترقب هذه الان الان هنالك
اسم جديد لهم الان يسمونهم
الجديد يملسون ملابسهم يرتدون
زيهم
بدء هذه الهدنه على الاقل اليوم
لا نقول يحتفلون بالعيد ولكن هناك وضع
انساني صعب للغايه هناك مصابين هناك جرحى
هناك اوضاع معيشيه
واقتصاديه صعبه للغايه يعني هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من اليوم هذا ما قال
الجيش السوداني انه وافق عليها شكرا لك
المحلل العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين
وهذا هي متابعه مع حضراتكم بصوت وصوره مره
اخرى لعمليات القصف المستمره في العاصمه
الخرطوم سنظل في هذه المتابعه البيت
الابيض قال انه لم يتم اتخاذ اي قرار بعد
باجلاء افراد البعثه الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيين من السودان اكد البيت الابيض
ان الولايات المتحده تستعد لمثل هذا
الاحتمال اذا لزم الامر وقال جونكر
المتحدث باسم الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض
ان رئيس بايدن وافق على خطه في وقت سابق
لنقل قوه امريكيه الى مكان قريب في حاله
الحاجه اليها للمساعده في اجلاء
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا الباحث والمحلل
السياسي محي الدين محمد مرحبا بك سيد محيي
هل تتوقع ان تدخل الهدنه بالفعل ما بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع حيز
التنفيذ خلال الدقائق القليله القادمه
اعتقد انها ستحتاج ربما ساعتين او ثلاث
ساعات حتى تتبلور رؤيه يعني اتفاق هو الان
طرح هذا الامر على ان يبدا من صباح اليوم
لكنه يعني بسبب العمليات لم لم يحدث والان
القوات المسلحه اعلى ستلتزم بالهده فربما
سنحتاج ان ننتظر بساعتين حتى نسمع ردا من
الطرف الاخر لانه طبعا الهدنه هذه مشكلتها
انه ليس هناك رعالها وليس هناك مراقبين
وليس هناك تحديد مسارات من تقدم بالهدنه
يعني هل قوات الدعم السريع هي من عرضت هذه
الهدنه التي وافق عليها الجيش ام ماذا حدث
مطروحه من امس انا اعتقد ان
الهدنه التي الجيش وافق عليها هي ذات
الهدنه التي طلبها الدعم السريع والتي
طالب بها المجتمع الدولي
وبالتالي اعتقد اننا الان بانتظار رد من
الدعم السريع في هذا الاتجاه واتوقع انه
سيقبل بالهده لانه هو من كان قد طلبها في
وقت سابق
المجتمع الدولي قد لماذا لم تنجح خلال
الفتره الماضيه كل محاولات وقف اطلاق
النار لايام قليله ما ان يتم الاعلان عن
هدنه الا ويتم اختراقها بعد ساعات قليله
للغايه لماذا
لانه الدعم السريع في كل مره كان يريد
تحسين التموضع بتاعه فبالتالي كان يعمل
على تطوير عملياته باتجاه القياده العامه
باتجاه القصر الجمهوري يعني نحن مراقبين
وقلنا نرى في الافطار عندما تعلن ان تكون
الساعه السادسه مساء قبل السادسه بخمس
دقائق
ونحن في محيط منطقه موجود فيها الدعم
السريعي يبدا باطلاق نار كثيف جدا ما يشير
الى انه يريد ان يستمر في المعركه مستغلا
الوضع الميداني في الوقت المعين هل تقول
ان الدعم السريع كان يعرض الهدنه وفي نفس
الوقت يقوم باستمرار
الهدنه كانت تطالب بها الامم المتحده
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الدول
ويتم الحديث عنها والقبول من الطرفين يعني
ما كانت مبادره من الدعم السريع كانت
مبادرات دوليه يوافق عليها الجيش وتوافق
عليها الدعم السريع لكن يتم خلقها لانه
الدعم السريع
ما الذي تغير على الارض حتى تكون هناك
هدنه حقيقيه لمده ثلاثه ايام اذا تم ذلك
نعم اول حاجه زادت المعاناه بالنسبه
للمواطنين بشكل كبير يعني كل مره تتراكم
المعاناه بشكل واضح وبالتالي هذا الامر
يستدعي هدنه العامل الاخر هو التغير في
موازين القوه على الارض بالنسبه للقوات
المسلحه التي استطعت ان تحسر
المتمردين في مساحات محدده لان الوقت
انتهى ساطرح هذا السؤال على دكتوره اماني
الطويل هل تتفق
مع من يمكن ان تستمر باعتبار ان الجيش
يشعر انه بات يسيطر اكثر وبالتالي يمكن
لهدنه ان تتم
لا انا اشك في هذا الكلام يعني الجيش قابل
للهدنه في تقديري وحددها لان المعارك حول
القياده العامه قد خفت والضغط عليه في
القياده العامه قد خف وهو يستطيع التعامل
مع الدعم السريع في احياء الخرطوم لكن
الموقف في الخرطوم او ظن على المستوى
العسكري ما زال مقلقا وبالتالي لا اعتقد
ان مثل هذه الهدنه التي هي بلا ضمانات
وبلا اطراف وسيطه وبلا يعني
هذه النقاط التي تطرحها الان لدعم السريع
يمكن ان تستمر فنرى ما الذي سيحدث اماني
طويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي بمركز
الاهرام للدراسات شكرا لك دكتور وايضا
للمحلل والباحث السياسي محي الدين محمد
كنا معكم في هذه المتابعه وسنستمر ايضا
لمتابعه الساعات القليله القادمه هي لحظات
جديده ربما تنعقد فيها الامال على قدره
الطرفين
على انجاز حقيقي لهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
التغطيه مستمره وسيكون معكم في الساعه
المقبله الزميل ابراهيم بدر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات